iteration seems like a very specific
process for most products I mean
entrepreneurs you need to analyze data
and act accordingly to improve your
specific monetization model and it can
vary a lot by product but are there any
instances where we can provide specific
actionable tips for a given product
actually yes companies in the game
industry seems to follow a few proven
path for increasing revenue first
promote certain items at the right
situation for heavy gamers the challenge
here is to identify these players and to
find the right situations second offer
an item with a big discount only to the
potential paid users the challenge is to
segment these users and control the
exposure of this discount third use ads
for non paying users the challenge is to
blend the ads and protect the experience
so these users will still love the game
and for everyone else we've got some key
takeaways for this lesson in the next
video